bonjour à tous nouveaux débats sur tv 78
radio sensations dans la perspective des
élections municipales et du premier tour
le 15 mars prochain dispositif
exceptionnel pour une ville
exceptionnelle versailles chef lieu du
département est des yvelines ville la
plus peuplée du département aussi
versailles cité royale attise les
convoitises
huit candidats sont déclarés à la date
de cet enregistrement le dimanche 23
février quatre candidats sont déjà avec
nous pour ce premier débat en plateau
nous aurons quatre 4 autres candidats
plus tard donc quatre candidats beau
temps de parole seront chronométrés pour
cette émission nous avons effectué aussi
un tirage au sort pour savoir qui
prenait la parole en premier essai vous
à jackman qui avait été choisi par le
hasard tête de liste rassemblement pour
versailles vous êtes la candidate
investie par le rassemblement national
le rn ou plutôt le fn qui avait réuni 10
% des voix en 2014 chef d'entreprise
dans la vie ce n'est pas votre première
expérience politique puisque vous étiez
candidate en ile-de-france lors des
élections législatives de 2012 et 2017
respectivement en seine-et-marne et dans
le val d'oise
versailles c'est donc un retour aux
sources pour vous expliquez nous
pourquoi les électeurs doivent t'ils
voté pour vous le 15 mars prochain
je sens déjà tout d'abord un grand merci
de nous recevoir ce soir
pourquoi et bien écoutez effectivement
comme vous l'avez souligné je suis né à
versailles j ai grandi j'ai fait mes
études
j'y réside depuis le 25 ans et avec
l'ensemble de l'équipe nous avons fait
ce constat d'évolution de versailles au
fil au fil des années aujourd'hui faire
ça il fait face à de grandes
problématiques vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure et est la proie de nombreuses
convoitises et clairement je pense que
peut le dire aussi sous la menace d'un
certain nombre de choix gouvernementaux
donc effectivement dans ce cadre là
d'ailleurs parce que par les deux listes
rassemblement national je tiens à
souligner que c'est une réelle liste
d'union
puisque ce n'est pas seulement un
soutien mais nous avons de plusieurs
membres de la droite populaire qui nous
ont rejoint ainsi qu'un certain nombre
de candidats non-inscrits n'appartenant
à aucune formation politique
particulière donc à cet effet
effectivement il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui dans le paysage ambiant
j'irai à l'instar de la politique
nationale nous sommes les seuls à être
capable de donner un minimum de
visibilité justement et de clarté dans
les décisions ce qui aujourd'hui manque
quand même cruellement à versailles
françois de mazières tête de liste union
pour versailles vous était évidemment le
maire sortant de la ville maire depuis
2008 adjoint en charge de la culture
durant 13 années auparavant réunis il y
a 6 ans dès le premier tour avec 55% des
voix vous avez été aussi député entre
2012 et 2017
pour cette campagne vous avez reçu le
soutien du rassemblement yvelinois
coalition des représentations locales
des républicains de libre ou encore de
génération terrain même question
pourquoi les vallées versailles et
doivent-ils renouvelé leur confiance en
vous le 15 mars prochain
d'un côté je connaissais la confiance de
l'équipe
c'est une équipe qui est effectivement
depuis plusieurs années se bat pour
cette ville qu'elle aime profondément
c'est une équipe plus d'unions parce que
pour nous l'important c'est de se battre
pour versailles en dehors d'ailleurs des
problématiques nationales même si comme
vous l'avez dit nous sommes soutenus par
un certain nombre de partis pour nous
c'est pas un combat d'étiquettes c'est
un combat passion pour cette ville c'est
une passion que j'ai depuis longtemps
versailles est une ville exceptionnelle
c'est vrai on y vit bien
ctv qui au cours de ces dernières années
a reçu énormément de prix dans les
classes mots qui existent que ce soit
dans le domaine écologique parce que
nous avons depuis des années cette
ambition marseille est une ville verte
c'est un peu notre slogan et nous avons
beaucoup travaillé en ce sens n'a pas
entendu cette élection pour que ça soit
mis à vraiment au premier plan de nos
priorités de mai que le développement
économique les gens peuvent constater le
nouveau quartier des chantiers c'est un
quartier assez exceptionnelle qui n'a
une nouvelle image aussi un autre vie
qui complète tout le travail qu'on a
fait sur la rénovation du patrimoine
en bref versailles c'est vraiment un
engagement pour nous très important et
nous avons envie de poursuivre ce
travail que nous avons mené depuis
quelques années et nous savons que nous
avons surtout l'énergie pour continuer à
le faire
fabien bouglé tête de liste en avant
vers sa une liste que vous définissez de
droite république
les écologistes vous êtes conseiller
municipal d'opposition depuis 2014 il y
a 6 ans vous aviez rassemblé 7,8 pour
cent des voix sur votre nom vous êtes
connu pour votre engagement par le passé
contre le mariage pour tous et plus
récemment contre le développement de
l'énergie éolienne vous avez sorti un
ouvrage à ce propos pourquoi les
électeurs doivent t'ils vous faire
confiance dans trois semaines
bonjour merci beaucoup de me donner la
parole ce soir
vous l'avez dit ça fait six ans que je
suis conseiller municipal d'opposition à
versailles les versaillais avait eu la
gentillesse de me m'attribuer leur
confiance et je me présente à eux
aujourd'hui avec mon équipe pour et bien
donné une autre politique à notre ville
j'ai pu constater pendant ces 6 on
demande à des problèmes d' écoute des
problèmes de démocratie locale notamment
dans la sphère du boulevard de la
république où on avait souhaité le maire
sortant avait souhaité couper
l'intégralité des arbres de cette de ce
boulevard est donc il ya effectivement
dans ma liste une liste d'union le livre
sur le tour introduction une liste
d'union à l'essai s'est effectivement
liste d'union de droite républicaine
authentique et écologique qui regroupe
tous les partis politiques des personnes
identifiées dans tous les partis
politiques de droite
quel qu'il soit mais dont la couleur à
sion politique n'a pas à émerger dans le
cadre de notre liste nous sommes des
citoyens indépendants des partis
politiques quand je crois qu'aujourd'hui
les partis politiques sont discrédités
en grande partie et c'est pour ça qu'on
ait une liste citoyenne et je suis très
fier de mon équipe qui est une équipe de
personnes compétentes qui veulent
vraiment gérer la ville au quotidien
avec une équipe de 12 2 12 adjoint qui
m'accompagneront dans cette mission
merci avant de donner la parole arnaud
mercier petite précision sur le taux d'
introduction et de conclusion si vous
pouviez ne pas vous interpellez puisque
c'est plus simple pour pour les coûte
notamment pour la présentation des
candidats arnaud mercier donc tête de
liste une nouvelle énergie pour les
versailles et vous êtes chef
d'entreprise est à la tête de plusieurs
associations locales vous est notamment
le créateur du versailles club affaires
politiquement
vous étiez membre de la majorité
municipale entre 2008 et 2014
à ce titre vous siégiez aussi à l'époque
en tant que conseiller d'agglomération
de versailles grand parc
c'est donc vous aussi votre retour dans
les affaires politiques locales pourquoi
les électeurs doivent t'ils vous faire
confiance le 15 mars
alors en fait on a créé une liste divers
droite et centristes l'objectif est
d'avoir une véritable action sur
versailles est un surtout une remontée
d'information à tous les niveaux et ça
c'est très important donc c'est à dire
de la démocratie locale c'est à dire que
justement on veut mettre en place des
commissions extra musique stra municipal
qui seront constitués d'habitants de
versailles évidemment d'élus mais
l'objectif c'est de faire remonter des
informations par exemple ça peut être
des commissions extra-municipales sur la
circulation sur le transport sur
l'économie etc
et puis surtout il ya quelque chose qui
est très important au niveau de
versailles qui doit être développé
c'est la partie économique moi je vois
avec mon club avec très peu de moyens on
arrive à faire des choses tu es très
belles choses on voit que versailles est
connu dans le monde entier que les
portes sont ouvertes partout
nous on a pu aller dans plusieurs
capitales à l'étranger pour faire
développer l'économie versaillaise et je
pense que c'est très important
c'est très important aussi pour trouver
des moyens pour s'occuper réellement du
social aussi sur versailles
ce qu'il manque actuellement merci pour
ce premier tour de table on jette déjà
un coup d'oeil à avaux temps de parole
vous êtes à peu près tous à une minute
quinze minutes 20 première thématique de
ce débat l'environnement en jeu
forcément devenu prioritaire dans cette
campagne qui s'impose à tout sujet
systémique aussi qui est l'environnement
mobilité consommation espaces verts
rénovation des bâtiments tout ou presque
est concerné par la thématique de
l'écologie versailles dispose de près de
87 ha de deux squares jardins et espaces
forestiers
c'est une ville aussi pionnière en la
matière par exemple pour le zéro phyto
appliquée depuis 2009 sur l'ensemble de
la ville versailles c'est aussi une
ville où la voiture est très présente
avec des axes routiers large qui la
traverse trois gars là en ville et à
terme
à long terme la ligne 18 qui doit
arriver alors quelles sont vos
propositions pour l'environnement fabien
bouglé on va commencer avec vous parmi
vos propositions j'ai relevé la
suppression de la publicité
dans la zone historique de la vie tout à
fait la publicité donc sera supprimée
dans la zone historique de la ville avec
un plan progressif de suppression de
toute publicité dans le reste de la
ville mais on est surtout il vous l'avez
souligné la liste des arbres puisque
l'équipe précédente voulait couper les
arbres du carré saint louis
couper les arbres du boulevard de la
république couper les arbres de l'avenue
de saint cloud et nous nous sommes la
liste des arbres j'ai à mes côtés jean
cigala qui a été président de
l'association des 100 arbres et qui a
milité pour éviter cette gabegie et
cette destruction massive et donc nous
nous sommes pour le maintien des arbres
dans la ville
nous sommes aussi pour le fait de
replanter des arbres parce qu'en fait
c'est un enjeu écologique majeure c'est
un appui à carbone c'est un est donc là
dessus nous sommes très très vigilants
et c'est pour ça que nous nous disons de
droite mais aussi écologistes et j'ai
obtenu lorsque j'ai été élu un
référendum pour justement lutter contre
la suppression des armes beauval la
république référendum que nous avons
emporté à 66% des voix et qui a souhaité
ne pas aboutir au projet du maire
sortant qui consistait à mettre le
stationnement payant boulevard de la
république et à supprimer les arbres
centenaires de cette avenue est donc on
nous nous réjouissons d'avoir dans notre
liste est d'avoir regroupé tous ces
amoureux de la nature et de
l'environnement
françois de mazières on comprend où vous
êtes visé peut-être que vous pourrez
répondre à ce qui a été dit votre
programme prévoit notamment le
développement des transports en commun
propres installer une déchetterie et
puis aussi parmi eux beaucoup de mesures
créer un conseil environnemental des
jeunes oui j'ai alors tout cas je me
suis permis datant effectivement parce
que c'est vrai qu'entre temps de dire
que notre scoop les arts est absolument
ridicule
tout simplement parce que nous en avons
plus planté qui l'ont amené obligé quand
on entretient réellement une ville un
objet de couper des armes quand ceux ci
sont en mauvaise santé
ça a été le cas comme ça se pratique
dans toutes les villes il se trouve que
le bilan au sur les six dernières années
est positif de plus de 200 arbres
ce qui n'est pas rien dans une école au
trou et effectivement il ya beaucoup
d'armes et c'est un des chances que nous
avons nous autres versez y est d'avoir
cet environnement exceptionnel
tout notre travail depuis effectivement
maintenant plusieurs années c'est de
renforcer sa dimension de la ville verte
comme je disais tout à l'heure c'est
même le slogan de notre vie nous
regarder les plans que j'ai fait tilt et
avec mon équipe vous verrez versailles
ville verte
pourquoi parce que versailles c'est
vraiment la ville de l' équilibre entre
le construit et la nature vous avez à
l'intérieur même de la ville des jardins
nous ont beaucoup développé ce qu'on
appelle se voulait ces traversées
urbaines autres les cartes et nous avons
ouvert au cours de ces dernières années
huit passages urbain ce qui est très
important dans une vie comme la nôtre et
les versaillais ont pris conscience du
travail extraordinaire que nous avons
fait notamment pour préserver du côté la
gare des chantiers ces bassins
historiques qui était desbassyns dans
laquelle végétation avait poussé et
aujourd'hui ce sont des venues des
jardins donc en fait cette caricature
que l'on fait de nous est un peu
ridicule nettement et elle est d'autant
plus ridicule que nous sommes consacrées
par tous les bilans qui existent au
niveau national que nous avons reçu un
nombre de prix en ce domaine qui sont
assez exception ce que nous voulons
faire c'est renforcer évidemment cette
politique qui fait partie pour nous des
priorités alors avant de vous donner la
parole on va écouter les autres
candidats sur ce point est un point
technique aussi monsieur de manière si
vous pouviez ne pas taper sur la table
pour qu'on entende bien ce que vous
dites justement et vos propositions
madame jacquemin sur sur l'environnement
j'ai noté que vous souhaitiez lutter
contre la bétonisation de la ville est
ce que ça veut dire qu'avec vous n'y
aura pas de construction de nouveaux
logements à versailles c'est un peu
radicale de le dire comme ça maintenant
il est clair que une démographie en un
accroissement démographique effréné
ne se fait pas sans ne se fait pas sans
dommages on constate aujourd'hui dans
les grands projets ceci à notre sens
doivent être complètement revu parce que
effectivement comme monsieur mazères
vous parler d'une réussite absolue à
chantier vous pourrez mettre en avant
les économies qui ont été faites mais
sincèrement depuis que le développement
durable a été intégré à versailles on
n'a jamais eu autant de béton donc là
quand même c'est comme un petit peu
c'est un petit peu paradoxal par rapport
à lancer un projet qui était une immense
dalle de béton coulé avec un centre
commercial est également un multiplexe
alors il ya une grosse effectivement
peut-être que dans 20 ans quand les deux
petits arbres qui ont été plantés auront
poussé peut-être qu'on pourra dire ça
sera un peu vert mais l'a pour l'instant
franchement
j'avoue que je vais prendre que je veux
prendre un train puisque j'ai
l'impression effectivement d'être régis
j'ai grandi j'ai grandi j'ai grandi à
mon tennis et je pense que c'est un
copié collé ce point qui s'est terminée
aujourd'hui du coup vos propositions
pour le futur
alors elles sont très claires c'est
qu'effectivement nous ce que nous
souhaitons et dans le dans le cadre des
grands projets et c'est affreusement
manquant c'est assez novateur cia ce
plan d'amélioration de qualité de l'air
qui me paraît vraiment extrêmement
importants et par un soutien justement
aux habitants il existe un certain
nombre de on se rend compte dans les
études environnementales
qu'effectivement il ya un problème de
circulation dans versailles ça très
clairement et le plein de circulation et
de stationnement doit être totalement
revue effectivement avec des
stationnements aux entrées de la ville
qui sont à des coûts abordables avec de
la navette propre ça on est on est bien
d'accord là dessus mais au-delà de ça on
se rend compte que la première source de
pollution de versailles qui est plus est
est lié à la vétusté des moyens de
chauffage dans les habitations
donc effectivement nous souhaitons
mettre en place une cellule qui est
parce qu il existe un certain nombre de
dispositifs dont on n'a pas forcément
totalement connaissance et s'ils peuvent
être c'est compliqué à mettre en oeuvre
il me semble qu effectivement c'est un
bon axe vis-à-vis de l'ensemble des
habitants de versailles il ya également
le plan de circulation douce très
clairement je sais que monsieur le maire
vous traversez vais le versailles à vélo
régulièrement je vous en suis admiratif
parce que personnellement je trouve ça
vraiment aujourd'hui extrêmement
dangereux surtout les petits trucs là
aussi ça doit être encouragé et
effectivement désenclaver le centre les
horaires de circulation des camions qui
abîment clairement la voirie
pour des raisons c'est inexplicable
certaines rues ont été refaites
pourquoi pas avec du goudron anti bruit
ça existe ça vous dit pas tellement plus
cher demain pourquoi je voulais il ya
toute l'équipe
notre équipe a construit une kyrielle de
solutions on en a plein c'est juste pour
le tendre âge où je comprends pas
renvoyer que vous puissiez pu parler des
vrais sujets arnaud mercier et dans
votre programme vous souhaitez vous
aussi et stopper la bétonisation est
réellement fleurir versailles je précise
que versailles et à quatre fleurs selon
la belle des villes et villages fleuris
et qu'il y a trois communes dans les
yvelines qui ont ce label
elle en avait deux il ya à peine de six
ans
monsieur mercier du coup sûr celle
devrait peut-être alors en fait je peux
me tromper mais je crois qu'on a 1 4
fleurs parce que il faut qu'il y ait
quatre fleurs minimum pour au moins une
ville qui est plus de 80000 habitants
donc il faudrait il faudrait revoir ça
mais voilà parce qu'il n'y a pas eu plus
de fleurs y a pas plus d'arbres depuis
depuis qu'ils avaient de fleurs moi mon
objectif de toute manière ce n'est pas
d'abattre des arbres
moi j'habite juste à côté justement de
rue de la république et j'ai vu les
arbres coupés j'ai vu des personnes
arrivées à 5 heures du matin pour couper
ces arbres et j'ai vu surtout aucun
arbre malade donc ça c'est un vrai
problème
moi mon objectif ce n'est pas de
supprimer des aliments je trouve que
c'est dommage je suis fils
d'horticulteurs donc autant dire que les
arbres ça me parle et mais surtout en
termes de qualité on va dire verte il
important surtout d'entretenir c'est à
dire que là les plus les peuls ou sur un
état détestable qu'il y à des harkis ont
été quand il y en a il ya des arbres qui
ont été coupées jamais jamais changé
jamais replanter etc etc
donc c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment très très important il faut
reverdir et surtout refleurir c'est bête
mais les fleurs dans une ville c'est
vraiment très agréable pour les
habitants et particulièrement pour ceux
qui n'ont pas les moyens d'avoir un
jardin à versailles et surtout ce qui se
passe au niveau du verre là il ya un
vrai problème au niveau du verre et
chantier typique par rapport à ça c'est
à dire que sur la partie publique
on a quelques arbres pas beaucoup doit y
en avoir une quinzaine ou une vingtaine
et sur la partie en fête privée
il y a des jardins qui sont privés sur
lequel personne n'a accès sur la partie
nouvelle je parle et ça c'est vraiment
dommage on est en train de privatiser en
fait le vert et ça c'est un vrai
problème
plus globalement ce qu'il faudra mettre
en place ces structures proactif c'est à
dire que justement on parlait tout à
l'heure des mesures d'économies
qui peuvent être mis en place dans les
appartements et cetera il faut que la
mairie soit les sache prendre de
téléphone pour les contacter un peu de
retard je voudrais réagir et après
monsieur de mazières et on passerait de
thématiques puisqu'il n'y a pas que
celle des adversaires de gouverneur est
lui qui est un présent puisqu'elle est
symptomatique de la façon de gérer la
politique locale de l'équipe en place
c'est que il ya des personnes qui se
sont attachés aux arbres pour empêcher
la coupe des arbres il y avait des les
agents municipaux de monsieur de
mazières qui était avec des
tronçonneuses a menacé ces personnes
donc ça c'est la vision de la démocratie
locale de l'équipe en place c'est à dire
pas de concertation on prend une
décision politique et on en a rien à
faire de la population or la convention
darus qui est une convention
internationale oblige toutes décisions
et n'ont rien un impact environnemental
de demander à la population son avis et
nous en tant que élus et élues de
versailles maire de versailles et mon
équipe on fera très en sorte que la vie
de la population soient prises en compte
surtout pour les décisions ayant un
impact environnemental françois de
mazières ans en tant que maire sortant
évidemment vous êtes souvent mentionnée
est visé par les propos de vos opposants
politiques mais votre temps de parole
sera le même donc si vous réagissez à
chaque fois vous aurez moins de temps je
vous je vous préviens pour le reste du
village
il ya une forme d'inégalité de certaine
façon car on entend que c'est évidemment
on critique le même pour la quatrième
fleur il faut savoir que c'est un jury
national qui n'a strictement rien à voir
avec le fait qu'il y ait quatre vingt
mille habitants
si le jury national vous écouter ils
seraient scandalisées ont fait la
quatrième fleur pourquoi nous l'avons
parce qu'une politique véritablement
écologique c'est une politique qui prend
en compte toutes les dimensions
justement de l'environnement dans une
vie et c'est le cas particulier de
versailles notamment avec effectivement
le fait de versailles a été la ville une
des premières villes zéro phyto c'est
aussi le fait que nous faisons très
attention à l'économie de l'eau à
versailles ont créé des poches sur les
différentes avenues versailles et
lorsqu'un arrose la ville de versailles
on utilise ses poches de exedra
excellent quand j'entends cette histoire
sur l'île
célèbre boule 20 la république c'est
tout simplement parce que nous avons va
nécessiter de créer une piste cyclable
je tiens toujours mes 60 ans parce que
le travail ici clame cibles étaient des
français en stationnement possible et
c'est aussi de manière puisque vous
aviez répondu mais qu'on peut aussi vous
aurez simplement pistes cyclables mais
c'est ça la réalité tout le monde le
sait et nous sommes engagés parce que
dans le prochain mandat
si nous sommes réélus nous fassions
cette paix si calmes qui est absolument
stratégique
et bien sûr on maintiendra les armes car
il a été nécessaire de couper des armes
et en étendant à replanter il faut lui
dire merci vous avez vous avez du coup
un peu d'avancé sur les autres candidats
sur le temps de parole je vous propose
de passer à un autre débat puisque le
temps passe on est déjà à la moitié de
ce premier débat pour les 4-8 quatre
débuts candidats à versailles la
démocratie peut-être locale mais très
rapidement puisqu'on l'a déjà abordé 86
mille habitants il ya huit conseils de
quartier dans la ville
est-ce suffisant quelles sont vos
propositions sur le sujet proposition
principale pour qu'on puisse parler d'un
autre sujet l'attractivité du territoire
qui est très importante avec les grands
projets qui arrivent à versailles arnaud
mercier vous souhaitez créer des
commissions extra-municipales comment ça
fonctionne et ça fonctionnerait et
quelques pourrait-elle décidé ces
commissions alors en fait j'ai rien
inventé puisque on les avait mis en
place ce que j'étais aussi conseiller
municipal à viroflay et ça a été mis en
place avec enflait depuis très très très
très longtemps
et l'idée c'est de moi j'étais toujours
fasciné par la compétence des habitants
mois sur sur viroflay j'habitais la rue
des prés au bois qu'à moitié à viroflay
la moitié à versailles on parlait de
l'a86 il y a les habitants je me
rappelle il ya 30 ans qui nous avait dit
un certain nombre de choses qui seront
révélées être exact trente ans plus tard
donc c'est un petit peu dommage de pas
utiliser cette compétence des habitants
et l'idée de ces commissions extra
municipales c'est justement de faire
remonter cette information de la part
des habitants
ce sont des choses qui sont compliqués à
gérer parce qu'on sait très bien aussi
que quand on est élu et quand on est
maire ceux qui viennent aussi à ce genre
de commission ce sont sa peut être
l'opposition etc
peu importe
ça se gère ça se gère ça se gère c'est
pas toujours très facile mais ça se gère
mais surtout on a de l'information voilà
donc circulation comme je disais
transport etc etc
lui et tous les sujets pourront être
abordés l'idée globale de toute manière
pas revoir mon équipe c'est la remontée
d'informations camjac main sur ce sujet
de la démocratie locale vous voulez
aussi consulter la population alors sur
quel sujet dans quel cadre
alors c'était bien il ya un certain
nombre de projets assez importants qui
sont les grands projets d'urbanisme en
soi que la ville
enfin il ya comme des décisions qui ne
peuvent pas être prêt sans consulter les
versets je pense par exemple à la grande
poste
un certain nombre de grands projets du
regain d'urbanisation il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui il existe un certain
nombre d'instances dans versailles qui
sont les conseils de quartiers qui sont
très mal utilisé c'est qu'enfin chercher
un compte-rendu rien et à jour et c'est
uniquement pas consultatif mais les
visites des élus qui sont rendus auprès
des auprès des conseils de quartier
aujourd'hui sont dans le cadre d'
informations descendantes et je vous
rejoins complètement monsieur mercier
elle sait que quand on lit les rapports
quand on lit les ces travaux des
conseils de quartier on a une mine d'or
qui est absolument inexploité enfin le
versailles à del et versailles et ont du
talent ça remonte extrêmement mal et
effectivement il ya un certain nombre de
sujets sur lesquels quand on se rend
auprès des différents membres des
conseils de quartier quand on la visite
quand on regarde les gens d'abord un les
versaillais ne sont pas tellement
informé qu on fait du fait qu'ils
peuvent aller qui peuvent y aller et
qu'ils ont dans leur quartier des gens
qui sont qui ont même sens du service et
qui sont leur disposition et
deuxièmement au sein des conseils de
quartier c'est très descendance n'est
pas ascendant
donc nous voulons vraiment faire
fructifier ces structures clairement
effectivement sur un certain nombre de
sujets importants et majeur pour la
ville
ça ne peut pas se faire nous sommes des
fervents défenseurs de la démocratie
participative c'est d'ailleurs de la
même façon qu'avec l'ensemble de
l'équipe on a construit le programme et
que chacun et chaque colistiers il a
activement participé
voilà voilà
possibilité transparence de
l'information parce qu'aujourd'hui par
exemple sur cette question des conseils
de quartier à les voir sur le site de la
mairie certains ne sont pas à jour
depuis 2015 2016 sont justes introuvable
fabien bouglé vous souhaitez vous aussi
consultés par référendum la population
sur l'environnement et les grandes
questions de la vie quotidienne alors
sur l'environnement c'est obligatoire en
version de la convention internationale
d'art us ça c'est une obligation
en revanche sur les grands chantiers par
exemple dossier pion qui est
actuellement amiante est donc le grand
dossier de plusieurs hectares que le
maire veut construire l'ancienne caserne
l'ancienne caserne plan qui est dans le
parcours au service mais qui étend le
pack historique du château de versailles
nous voulons soumettre à référendum dans
la mesure où rien n'est transparent sur
le sujet que les dossiers sont choisis à
l'avance par l'équipe actuelle
en revanche il ya la démocratie locale
le fait de pouvoir visionner le conseil
municipal en vidéo conférence
le fait de pouvoir avoir accès à un
système d' écoute de nos concitoyens
avec un médiateur municipal lorsque ça
ne va pas avec les services on a des
retours de terrain qui nous disent on
sollicite la mairie on n'a pas de
réponse deux mois trois mois après on
aura une obligation de nos
collaborateurs de répondre dans les sept
jours à compter d'une demande avec le
nom d'un interlocuteur un mail d'un
interlocuteur et une ligne directe
nous avons constaté et beaucoup de mes
concitoyens constatent qu'il n'y a pas
d' écoute et nous nous voulons être là
l'équipe de les coudes ce qui éviterait
et ce qui aurait pu éviter la
catastrophe de la rue du vieil
versailles où la poche de la nappe
phréatique a conduit à au fait qu'on a
dû évacuer trois immeubles qui sont
actuellement en extrêmement dégradée du
fait des problèmes de deux sous sol de
la rue du biez versailles et là tout ça
s'il y avait eu la cote de nos
concitoyens ça ne serait pas arrivé donc
je pense que ça ce sont deux aspects
très importants démocratie locale et
écoute de nos concitoyens ce sont
vraiment des éléments clés de notre
programme
alors françois de mazières libre à vous
de répondre est évidemment à ce qui est
dit vous avez peu de temps pour réagir
ou alors vous aurez moins de temps plus
tard sur la question de la démocratie
locale j'ai noté que vous souhaitez
organiser des réunions de quartier
régulièrement plus régulièrement
mais c'est déjà le cas si vous voulez
les conseils de quartier sont actifs
gérés reprise s'inscrit sur votre site
madame jacques en mai mais c'est vrai
qu'elle est assez récent dans
l'implication dans la ville il se posa
quelques os n'est peut-être pas très
bien le fonctionnement réel les conseils
de quartiers qui sont très importants et
nous qu'il ya le visible de projets que
j'ai laissé mes mots de monsieur dommage
il se trouve que chaque fois d' si vous
voulez qu'il y à une modification qui
touchera lapoirie nous consultons bien
sûr les conseils de quartier et les
conseils de quartier serait un peu vexé
d'entendre votre réflexion car depuis
six ans ils ont beaucoup travaillé
il se trouve aussi que j'ai tenu
beaucoup de réunions dans l'ensemble des
quartiers
je pense qu'on peut pas dire que ce soit
un maire qui connaît pas à l'écarter j'y
suis très souvent et j'y suis
effectivement souvent même seul ou en
vélo pour aller voir ce qui se passe est
allé voir comment les projets se
développent les consultations chaque
fois qu'il ya des programmes lourds je
pense notamment au chantier à d'autres
nous allons fonder grande réunion où il
y avait 300 personnes parfois ces
réunions elle existe et je pense
également que dans le prochain mandat
s'il est versé et continue à nous faire
confiance
nous continuerons à faire ce travail de
terrain qu'un point nommé il est
absolument le seul regret pour réagir
rapidement messieurs merci entre ne veut
pas c'est un autre sujet important des
conseils de quartier sont que le conseil
de quartier complètement tenus par les
élus du conseil municipal sortant c'est
à dire les élus de françois de mazières
ce qui fait qu'en fait il n'y a pas de
concertation rançais dell'arte pouvoir
de françois pourquoi dans la sphère du
boulevard de la république le conseil de
quartier a donné un avis favorable au
projet d'abattage des arbres et qu'il y
a eu un référendum qui a montré que 66 %
de la population s'y opposer ça prouve
bien que le conseil de quartier n'est
pas représentatif de la population loge
à leur effondrement de la république a
été contestée par beaucoup de personnes
je les fais parce que effectivement
hérité un état et pourtant faut imaginer
il faut imaginer une tension que je n'ai
jamais vécu ailleurs que des gens
effectivement s'oppose aux décisions qui
ont été prises et votée en conseil
municipal et est effectivement anormal
alors ensuite vous aime bien les paye
ses conversations et éteindre et du
besoin de matières vous vous prenez
beaucoup d'inventions sur le temps de
parole je sais à vous
vous posez une question oui je sais je
vous avoue aussi qu'on est soumis aux
règles du csa
est ce que monsieur mercier vous
souhaitiez encore rajouter quelque chose
sur la démocratie locale vous avez pour
le coût du retard ou on passe à
l'attractivité du territoire il ya
beaucoup d'enjeu dans les années à venir
à versailles évidemment non je veux bien
continuer juste sur la partie des
conseils de quartier en fait donc que ce
soit tenu par la mairie c'est pas un
problème il faut il faut quand même
savoir tenir un conseil de quartier que
ça se passe bien
en revanche il faut il ne faut pas que
ce soit un lieu de finalement de blocage
pour d'accès à certains élus en fait
c'est vécu pour certaines certains
habitants qui sont dans les conseils de
quartier qui disent bah moi en fait on
fait passer le temps le conseil de
quartier et puis du coup on dire non
mais vous passez pop directement par
l'élu vous passez par le conseil de
quartier et puis ensuite ce héros
montera alors souvent ça remonte pas
donc c'est un vrai problème
donc l'idée c'est pas de changer
tellement le mode de fonctionnement de
conseils de quartier c'est de faire
remonter l'information et de surtout
d'avoir un retour par rapport aux
informations qui sont qui sont issus de
localement on va passer à l'attractivité
du territoire puisque les sujets
dangereux non je ne manque pas pour
recadrer les chiffres 8 millions de
visiteurs en 2018 au château de
versailles c'est évidemment l'un des
sites les plus visités de france vers ça
et c'est aussi une ville qui va
accueillir les jo de 2024 avec les
épreuves d'équitation il ya enfin la
question du grand paris pour versailles
la ligne 18 arrivera en 2030
du coup quelles sont vos points de vue
sur tous ces sujets l'attractivité du
territoire c'est évidemment je le sais
très vaste mais je vais vous demandez
peut-être de sélectionner un point de
vue et un point de votre campagne
à chaque fois arnaud mercier je vous
redonne la parole sur ce sur ce sujet
vous voulez redonner vous son éclat
d'antan il sa place à l'international à
versailles oui tout à fait alors en fait
comme je vous ai indiqué tout à l'heure
moi avec mon tout petit club d'affaires
en fait dès que on arrive à l'étranger
et qu'on dit qu'on est versailles toutes
les portes sous réellement et donc ça
c'est un petit peu dommage qu'un maire
ne l'utilisent pas pour faire moi dans
mon cas par exemple placé pour les
entreprises mais c'est également pour le
monde de la culture c'est pour le monde
des artisans etc etc
ça se faire relativement facilement il
suffit juste d'avoir un petit peu de
volonté et puis c'est vrai d'avoir un
petit peu de réseau après pour rendre
attractive versailles et surtout en fait
c'est un c'est un ensemble de choses qui
sont assez compliqué à dire
très rapidement comme ça la vraie
difficulté le château est une énorme
chance pour versailles c'est aussi un
énorme handicap parce que finalement on
dit c'est le château qui va s'occuper
des touristes faire venir pour faire
venir les touristes dans versailles
il est nécessaire de leur offrir quelque
chose pour leur offrir quelque chose il
faut faire des événements de l'animation
ces derniers temps il y en a de moins en
moins on ne fait depuis le 14 juillet ce
qui pour moi qui suis républicain ça me
pose quand même quelques problèmes en
dehors du fait de l'animation mais il
faut pouvoir animer des choses déjà pour
du duo local et par rapport aux
touristes il y a des choses qu'on
pourrait mettre en place pour les faire
rester
je prends le cas de bruges qui elle
n'est qu'une ville pour faire rester les
gens qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait c'est
tout bête mais ça demande aussi à un
petit peu d'argent ils ont mis en place
un certain nombre de musées plein de
petits musées et à la fin de la matinée
un chien etc
a bah tiens mais j'ai pas vu ça si
machin est la fin de la journée il bat
qu'un jeu je vais prendre une nuit
d'hôtel
voilà et du coup se nuit d'hôtel mais
ils reviennent et rs le lendemain et il
consomme
voilà un jet main sur la question de
l'attractivité du territoire et tous ces
grands sujets il est clair qu
effectivement aujourd'hui le versailles
ne bénéficient pas de l'offre
touristique qui pourtant vous êtes bien
au delà du château on a un patrimoine
exceptionnel on jouit de ce cadre et on
n'en profite pas les commerçants n'en
profite pas les verser n'en profite pas
ou pas assez d'humour et là je vous
rejoins complètement un circuit complet
à redéfinir
c'est vrai quand on sort du château et
c'est de bonne guerre tout est fait les
boutiques sont à l'intérieur et c'est
les gens montent dans leur bus et ils
repartent
je pense qu'effectivement déjà redéfinir
un circuit un billet groupé développer
davantage l'offre touristique
complémentaire nous paraît fondamental
ce qui permettra de donner un large
soutien aussi à nos commerçants enfin
les commerçants indépendants
il se promenait dans versailles et quand
même
pour se rendre compte que grand nombre
de boutiques ferme une usine derrière
les autres hier matin qu'on est à
porsche anton je voulais prendre un café
et encore un commerçant fermé
historiquement le magasin de chaussures
ou ma grand mère m'a jeté mes chaussures
quand j'étais petite rue georges
clemenceau et dense est terminée ils
ferment donc il ya vraiment quelque
chose à faire
de ce point de vue là pour aider nos
commerçants sur le sur l'attractivité du
territoire par rapport à l'accueil des
jeux olympiques
effectivement tout doit être fait dans
cet esprit si c'est pour aller
construire quelque chose à l'autre bout
de versailles où ça va profiter où
finalement les gens resteront enfermés
dans leur hôtel parce qu'il n'y a aucune
infrastructure pour les ramener dans
versailles je suis pas convaincu sur le
grand paris sur le et sur le grand paris
ça reste on reste là dans le micmac
administratif de effectivement
versailles reste le théâtre de toutes
les convoitises
effectivement il ya le projet de cet
horrible ouest qui reste vraiment à
développer à définir et je pense
qu'effectivement on a une source
on a une source ga de développement et
d'attractivité qui est exceptionnel et
continuer à attirer les entreprises
effectivement moi j ai créé une
entreprise qui crée les emplois et je
voudrais qu'on continue dans ce sens là
pour que ça reste vraiment aussi
attractif françois de mazières sur cette
question le tourisme qui fait beaucoup
parler évidemment tous ces sujets
importants pour versailles il ya aussi
jeune et j'ai omis de mentionner mais la
question éventuelle de la fusion entre
le département des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine va pouvoir répondre
rapidement aux usa le touriste est
fondamentale et beaucoup de choses qui
ont été faites par l'office du tourisme
de la ville de versailles soutien et
c'est indispensable
nous avons prévu d'ailleurs de mettre la
localisation de l'office de tourisme
face à l'entrée des touristes c'est à
dire face à la gare rive gauche
ça fera partie de nos investissements
s'il verse à une seconde leur confiance
et puis nous avons rénové aussi le
palais des congrès parce qu'elle est
important que nous ayons ces outils pour
permettre un accueil effectivement de
manifestations qui permettent d'aider le
commerce local de versailles fabien
bouglé vous souhaitez vous valoriser la
marque versailles notamment c'est ce que
j'ai lu comment à travers qu'à l'action
tout à fait
on est tout à fait favorable fait de
valoriser en ressources propres la
marque versailles la mairie de
versailles avait oublié de la déposer au
niveau international on leur a donné un
coup de main manière constructive
parce qu'ils avaient loué la marque
versailles au film versailles pour 10000
euros donc ravi c'est quand même pas
beaucoup pour un budget de 25 millions
d'euros
et donc on a et donner un coup de main
aux équipes pour revaloriser et
atteindre un montant supérieur autour de
80 mille euros on à la porte on a là un
geste
il suffit de voir les prochaines
versions conseils municipaux les tout ça
est consigné dans les conseils
municipaux
donc on a donc une manne financière
incroyable en exploitation de produits
dérivés et nous on veut développer les
ressources propres il ya 7 à 8 millions
de touristes qui viennent à versailles
notre objectif c'est un euro à la fin du
mandat par touriste parce qu'on peut
faire des produits dérivés des t-shirts
des mugs et les jeux olympiques de 2024
nous donneront l'occasion d'exploiter
encore cette marque est par ailleurs on
peut également développer la marque au
niveau international avec ses produits
dérivés donc à la fois dans les
touristes exploitation la marque pour
les touristes locaux et exploitation la
marque au niveau international et par
ailleurs l'autre biais qui est très
important c'est que nous manquons
cruellement d'hôtel et personnellement
je suis plutôt favorable même si nous
mettrons en démocratie en application de
d'une consultation publique à prévoir un
hôtel à la place de la poste qui est une
poste en béton totalement ringarde et
nous nous voulons mettre en place un
grand hôtel là avec une architecture
classique en harmonie avec les lieux
pour maintenir les touristes et
d'ailleurs on mettra une
une taxe supplémentaire sur les bus pour
les bus qui ne reste qu'une journée
on va créer un péage supplémentaire pour
faire en sorte que les bus et que les
touristes restent sur place parce que ça
c'est un gros problème que nous avons à
versailles françois de mazières si vous
souhaitiez en tant que maire sortant
répondre je vous ai vu réagir quand
monsieur voulait commencer à a parlé oui
parce qu on a l'impression que ce boulet
a inventé toute la politique que nous
faisons notamment sur la valorisation de
la marque versailles qui fait partie
effectivement du travail que nous
faisons actuellement notamment avec une
agence spécialisée car il faut et que
l'on puisse valoriser davantage marc
versailles oui sauf quand au projet
quand on sait que les récits répond
monsieur bazire qui vous allez vous en
parlait encore canton projet qui est
celui de la poste c'est un projet
aujourd'hui qui est totalement bouclée
et monsieur googlé le sait bien c'est un
projet qui fera l'objet d'un nouveau
pôle si puisque le permis est déposé et
qu'il ait purgé des voies de recours et
donc si quelqu'un voulait faire autre
chose ça coûtera absolument une fortune
pour le dossier des chantiers
pourquoi n'était pas plancher ou est ce
que vous mettez dans votre programme
alors des choses qui sont déjà actés
parce que moi j'ai du mal à mettre
trouver sincèrement mais non si l'on
disait tout à l'heure je reviens sur la
démocratie participative et il ya des
choses qui sont déjà décidé on a du mal
à savoir où est-ce qu'on tout simplement
parce que c'est décidé et que la
construction va avoir lieu qu ici
quelques mois que l'ouverture se fera
dans deux ans deux ans et demi donc
milieu pratiquement du prochain monde
paraît normal de même alors je la mets
dans vos premières propositions par
exemple les innovations mais par ces
projets visite à lens après vous clé
fondamentale il est bouclée dans sa
conception la réalisation banlieue dans
ce monde si ça s'appelle de la bonne
chez cement alors très rapidement parce
que le temps passe il ya des sujets
d'importance à lui si à chaque fois vous
interpellez monsieur de magie a
forcément les rives répondre à ces
questions importantes
la question de la marque quand la mairie
oublie de le déposer la marque au niveau
international dis moi que c'est faux
françois aviez-vous déposé la marque au
niveau international avant que
n'intervienne vous l'avait déposée suite
à mon intervention en conseil municipal
et
un procès verbal que je communiquerai à
la population on ne peut pas fermer
alors comme ça va laisser répondre
monsieur peut-être de mazières sur cette
question très rapidement et puis on
passe à la question de la sécurité que
vous mentionnez tous dans votre campagne
la question de la masse et voulait être
un travail que nous avons fait notamment
effectivement à l'occasion vingt films
qu'à utiliser le nom de versailles
et effectivement nous avons travaillé
pour obtenir un an des indications qui a
été de l'ordre 80000 euros sur la marque
versailles on va passer à la question de
la sécurité provinciale dans ce débat
qui est diffusée sur tv 78 radio
sensations voit vos temps de parole
s'afficher vous êtes presque tous à
égalité un peu de retard pour monsieur
mercier
on va commencer avec vous madame
jacquemin on va rappeler quelques
chiffres à versailles j'ai noté 120 121
une caméra de vidéosurveillance la
police municipale qui est art mais aussi
depuis récemment équipé de caméras
piétons madame jacques moins sur la
question de la sécurité qu'est ce que
vous vous souhaitez faire de plus on
part d'un constat c'est que il n'est
plus une semaine sans qu'un incident
chaque fois de plus en ski à huy
clairement versailles était sûr ça
devient de moins en moins sûr clairement
ne parlons pas des couteaux de
cambriolages qu'on passe un petit peu
plus difficile mais effectivement c'est
une tolérance zéro ce point de vue là il
ya quand même des poches pas des
uniquement des quartiers dits sensibles
mais effectivement des poches qui
deviennent assez assez sens du jeu peu
la photo à l'appui vous pouvez on ne
peut plus garer sa voiture avenue de
sauts sans risquer d'avoir une vitre
brisée
on ne peut plus se promener sortir
d'avoir nos enfants qui sort d'un cinéma
le soir à 22h sang potentiellement se
prend un coup de couteau
il ya des caméras certes quel est le
taux de regard justement parce qu elles
de l'auto d'archivage liés à la
vidéoprotection s'éteint c'est un vrai
sujet après par contre je me réjouis je
veux aujourd'hui l'ensemble de l'équipe
on sait profondément réjouis puisque la
municipalité sortante après s'être
affiché sa fille sa fiche est encore
aujourd'hui largement très macron
compatibles finalement aujourd'hui on
était assez content voir en regardant le
dernier traque parce qu'on s'aperçoit
finalement devient aussi rn compatibles
pourquoi parce qu'effectivement ne
serait ce qu'au travers du au travers du
dispositif voisins vigilants qui vous
l'a effectivement on s'aperçoit que la
gestion et rennes ça marche puisque à
beaucaire ses 45% de cambriolages en
moins par exemple et bien effectivement
ce dispositif a été déployé dans bon
nombre de communes donc je me réjouis
d'ailleurs que la la rn compatibilité
finalement s'affiche dans les programmes
électoraux y compris celle de la
municipalité sortante puisque ça fait
partie de nos propositions que nous
avons affiché depuis un certain moment
donc effectivement sur la sécurité c'est
ça s'est pas renforcé aussi les échanges
avec la police nationale
augmenter les moyens humains et
matériels un petit peu plus de
prévention
un peu moins de pv aussi peut-être un
peu plus de sécurité c'est bien le temps
de ce débat avance n'aura pas le temps
d'évoquer la jeunesse je préfère vous le
dire tout de suite que c'était la
cinquième thématiques prévues
fabien bouglé sur la sécurité vous
parler d'explosion aussi vous aussi de
la délinquance explosion
l'exode je prends les chiffres du
parisien qui sont ceux du ministère de
l'intérieur il ya des doublements ou une
augmentation de 50% de certains délits
dans la villa moi mon voisin d'en face
vient de se faire cambrioler boulevard
de la reine
alors ces constats c'est parce que nous
sommes une liste d' écoute
nous avons des remontées du terrain et
comme nous écoutons les gens et bien
nous agissons après quand je vois que
place hoche garder chantiers qui sont
deux zones particulièrement touchées par
la délinquance il ya du trafic de drogue
place hoche jusqu'à 22 heures jusqu'à
demain minuit aux beaux jours plus tôt
pas de véhicules de police municipale en
station gens discutaient encore ce matin
au marché avec une personne qui habite
rien n'est fait
les personnes ont beau appeler la police
municipale la police nationale rien
n'est fait nous mettra en place une
police municipale plus importante en
baissant le budget de la voirie puisque
le budget de la voirie a explosé ces
dernières années et le budget de la
sécurité est passée de 5 % du budget
global à 3 % du budget global
la voirie est passé de 20 % en 2014 du
budget global à 30 % du budget global
eh bien nous ferons des économies sur la
voirie nous engagerons des policiers
municipaux
nous développons la vidéosurveillance
pour faire en sorte que la ville soit
beaucoup plus sûr et surtout nous ferons
en sorte d'arrêter de harceler
l'automobiliste en diminuant le
stationnement payant qui passera de 240
euros à 75 euros pour la zone
résidentielle et faire en sorte que les
personnes qui ont un stationnement
résidentiel puissent stationner partout
dans toutes les zones de versailles avec
un stationnement gratuit pendant 30
minutes pour alléger la pression sur les
automobilistes
et plutôt que de s'attaquer aux
automobilistes s'attaquer plutôt aux
délinquants avec une tolérance zéro
arnaud mercier vous souhaitez vous aussi
augmenter la sécurité au quotidien
comment par quel type d'action
alors en fait
l'accroissement à la sécurité c'est un
ensemble de petites choses qui font qu'à
la fin on arrive à des grands problèmes
je prends le cas de chantiers là c'est
assez différent puisqu'on a des gens qui
prennent des canapés pour les mettre
dans la rue pour vendre de la drogue
dehors j'ai jamais vu ça versailles ou
pas bon en fait qu'est ce qui se passe
est un ensemble de petites choses on met
des caméras ce qui est une très bonne
chose
sauf qu'on retire des policiers c'est
embêtant
et derrière les caméras on sait pas si
c'est visionner on sait très bien que
pour certains faiseurs en tout cas c'est
pas visionner c'est évident pardon génie
archives et non plus voilà c'est un chef
aimé ça
un temps très court par exemple sur
chantier qu'est ce qui se passe on a et
il y a donc un certain nombre de
logements hlm et dans ces logements hlm
les il ya de moins en moins deux
gardiens dans ses résidences et les
gardiens sont les yeux de pau par
rapport à la sécurité
donc du coup on n'a pas de remontée
d'informations donc les habitants de ces
hlm subissent la délinquance qui vient
soit de l'intérieur soient souvent de
l'extérieur on a retiré
on a retiré la police montée la police à
cheval en 2015
là la police nationale vient il ya
quelques jours de rétablir la police
montée à versailles donc c'était bien
quelque chose qui était utile il ya
quelque chose qui existe qui s'appelle
le clspd ce qui est une très bonne chose
c'est respect des c'est la prévention
contre la délinquance
c'est un partenariat entre la police
nationale la police municipale les
maisons de quartier enfin un certain
nombre de choses qui permet en fait de
faire de la prévention et surtout de
l'information pour savoir comment réagir
par rapport à de la drogue la
délinquance divers et variés ça a été
signé il ya quatre ans mais rien ne
s'est passé
donc il n'ya pas être coordination a
réellement de fait c'est un vrai
problème
après juste très rapidement sur la
police municipale il faudra leur donner
un peu plus de moyens parce que attendre
le bus pour elle et intervenir dans des
trucs c'est ptet pas forcément
directement
comment je crois que françois de
mazières veut donner plus de moyens à la
police municipale pour sur cette
question de la sécurité une minute
trente comme ça vous aurez tous le même
temps de conclusion ensuite qu'on a
augmenté le nombre des policiers
municipaux ajouté nous avons 24
policiers municipaux et nous avons
également équipé notre police municipale
d'armes à feu il nous avons récemment
équipé aussi de systèmes
d'enregistrement ce qui est important
pour que l'on puisse lorsqu'il ya
l'interpellation l'on puisse avoir des
preuves qu'ils soient enregistrés donc
des efforts très importants ont été
faits sur la vidéo protection comme ça a
été dit d'ailleurs je n'ai entendu
l'instant sommes effectivement passé il
y avait zéro caméra en 2008 nous en
sommes à a+ en bas c'est donc un système
en plus de contrôles qui se fait à
l'hôtel de police de la ville
le problème que nous rencontrons c'est
une baisse effectivement la présence à
police nationale puisque la police
nationale est mobilisée sont d'autres
vies car les statistiques montrent que
versailles reste une ville plus sûre que
d'autres et il faut en avoir conscience
certes ce n'est pas une situation idéale
car dans l'ensemble de notre pays
malheureusement la situation de la
sécurité s'est dégradée et versaient
reste encore villa session et nous
ferons effectivement des efforts
supplémentaires en augmentant le nombre
des policiers municipaux
mais quand j'entends tout à l'heure ce
qui a été dit sur les droits de
stationnement là permettez moi de dire
que c'est totalement illusoire pour deux
raisons d'abord si on a ses droits de
tarifs
c'est tout simplement pour mettre une
rotation une rotation des véhicules car
le payer le parking payant permet de
voir une plus grande rotation des
véhicules c'est très important pour
défendre le commerce de centre-ville
alors on va faire jouer en conclusion
vous aurez liberté de répondre mais pas
de relancer pour ce temps de conclusion
une parole
malheureusement arrivent à la fin de
l'émission ne peut pas durer pendant des
heures je sais que vous auriez aimé moi
aussi
on va devoir conclure cette émission on
prend l'ordre
inverse du temps de l'introduction d'un
quart no mercy vous allez commencer ce
temps de conclusion une nouvelle fois
parole libre vous pouvez aborder ce que
vous souhaitez revenir sur un débat ne
pas relancer en tout cas l'un des
candidats ça sera votre dernière
derniers temps de parole elle avait une
minute il s'est excusé une minute trente
à excuser minutes d'accord très bien non
moi mon objectif est l'objectif de
l'équipe c'est vraiment de faire
remonter de la formation donc c'est
l'information évidemment précise au
niveau des habitants mais aussi au sein
de la mairie elle même avec les
fonctionnaires qui sont là aussi pour
nous passer les informations donc c'est
une chose qui est très importante pour
pouvoir décider alors on n'en a pas
parlé du tout mais pour moi un vecteur
qui est très important c'est la partie
sociale j'ai été président de la mission
locale on a aidé les jeunes on a aidé
plus de 50% de jeunes durant la période
où j'étais président ça pu être mis en
place c'est aides pour les jeunes donc
du social pour proprement parler
pourquoi parce qu'on a mis en place un
vrai lien avec le monde économique avec
le monde des entreprises et je ne mets
pas l'un contre l'autre c'est l' inverse
temps quand on arrive à faire
fonctionner les deux ça fonctionne très
très bien c'est très efficace
tout le monde en est satisfait et et
c'est bien l'objectif de notre liste
c'est d'aider tous les concitoyens et
n'oubliez surtout personnes fabien
bouglé vous avez une minute 20 pour pour
conclure écoutez si les versailles et me
font l'honneur de
lire mr je serai le maire d'une ville
bienveillante une ville où la démocratie
locale sera au coeur de notre processus
de gouvernement ou l'écologie sera placé
au coeur parce qu'on la dise on l'a vu
tout à l'heure le débat sur les arbres
un débat important ce qui prouve que
c'est une question importante de nos
concitoyens une ville sécurisée avec une
police municipale renforcée une ville où
il fait bon vivre où mon équipe qui est
une équipe compétente d'hommes et de
femmes qui m'ont rejoint en qui je suis
avec qui je suis vraiment ravi de
travailler et bien on se mettra au
service de nos concitoyens et non pas à
notre propre service je ne suis pas un
professionnel de la politique
ça fait pas 25 ans que je suis en mandat
à versailles je suis dynamique
je veux avancer face à une équipe est
soufflée par des mandats successifs
et d'ailleurs je m'engage à ne faire que
deux mandats maximum
françois de mazières une minute pour
pour conclure je crois se voulait que la
bienvenue à travers ce débat que la
critique est facile et l'art est
difficile et je pense que les versets
pourront juger finalement lisons une
équipe qui a travaillé pendant plusieurs
années la situation de la ville et je
pense globalement bonne c'est comme ça
en tout cas que beaucoup de versailles
et nous témoignent leur confiance
aujourd'hui sur le marché quand on va
vers eux et je veux dire que tout notre
équipe nous avons vraiment envie de
continuer ce travail c'est un travail de
proximité c'est un travail de passion
c'est un travail de compétences aussi
parce que nous avons une équipe avec des
profils très différents et très
complémentaires c'est difficile
aujourd'hui de gérer une ville c'est
très facile de dire me faire ça on va
faire ça dans un contexte budgétaire
extrêmement délicat nous avons en plus
récemment encore était montrée comme une
ville très bien géré eh bien nous allons
continuer à le faire s'il versailles et
nous font confiance
merci beaucoup à jack main pour conclure
ce débat vous avez 40 secondes seulement
vous aviez de l'avancé aux autres
candidats m
il a écouté notre liste notre liste
d'union je pense que déjà rapidement
c'est qu'effectivement on souhaite la
même chose à versailles parce que la
gestion rm droite populaire ça marche on
l'a montré sur nos nombreuses communes
donc effectivement on veut absolument la
même chose pour versailles
on ne veut pas se contenter en fin de
mandat de pouvoir dire que versailles
reste plus sûr que d'autres elle doit
rester sur un point c'est tout je pense
que les parents de ce jeune garçon qui a
été poignardé à la sortie du cinéma
l'entendront parfaitement ça doit pas
être bue faire un petit peu mieux que
les autres on doit le faire bien un
point c'est tout on ne peut pas se
contenter d'être sur quelque chose de
médian de de flou à l'instar à l'instar
du gouvernement national la gestion rn
droite populaire ça fonctionne ça marche
résultat la pluie nous souhaitons
déployer avec l'ensemble de l'équipe
très vaste mais expérimenté voilà merci
la confusion merci à vous quatre on va
avoir besoin de paroles vous êtes
presque
merci pour votre participation presque
le même temps pour chacun d'entre vous
je rappelle que vous serez opposés à
quatre autres candidats arnaud aux yeux
jean michel boeri un de francs simon et
marc dias gamme à ce qu'on recevra dans
un autre débat merci encore ce premier
débat on le retrouve en replay sur notre
chaîne aux aussi sur radio sensations et
puis on peut vous suivre sur les
meetings qu'on diffus sur notre site
internet
merci beaucoup
[Musique]